David Pollock used to chase quarterbacks
for a living now he talks about them
College GameDay concludes its regular
season this Saturday live from army-navy
and they start at 9:00 a.m. Eastern on
ESPN David thanks for joining us what
stood out in that final four rankings
for you I think it was the same thing
everybody else thought just uh the
committee moved LSU ahead of Ohio State
listen LSU has the case Ohio State has a
case I think if you play the long game
in the consistency game you would
probably lean towards the Ohio State for
a season of domination no bad games
consistently showing up both sides of
the football but then you look at LSU
and you start looking the resume and
they got four wins in the top 13 and
that's pretty dadgum impressive and they
destroyed Georgia the number four team
in the country this week at the SEC
championship games I think just you know
man this year was the most important
year to have the number one seat by far
because number three can win the whole
thing it's the first time we've come
into where you go there's three
legitimate teams I think that if you
picked could be the favorite on any
given day so that's kind of crazy and
it's gonna be a heck of a play off
because of it ya know you know I brought
this up and I heard from my my friends
who live in Ohio where I grew up that
Ohio State look at what we did in the
second half and I said but what did you
not do in the first half I can't give
you credit for the second half if I
can't give you blame for the first half
and LSU from start to finish dominated a
Georgia team that you know didn't even
belong on the field with them so I I
know it's recency bias but I've looked
at LSU and you know what they did
against Alabama maybe doesn't look that
impressive but what they did against
Georgia in Atlanta you know I'm gonna
give them the nod here it's slight but I
would give them the non well then I
would say that the the best win of the
season period is LSU going to Tuscaloosa
and beating Alabama I mean if you want
to point to the most impressive thing to
me that was the the most impressive
thing because Alabama obviously at home
they don't lose they don't lose very
many games period and they had a guy
name to it quarterback so you know I
definitely think that was uh if you're
going to highlight one win that was the
best win I think that was the best one
in college football this season
and Clemson I know Dabo Sweeney loves
playing the underdog roll the old woe is
me and you know the committee didn't
want us in and they got us number three
here all right yeah let's see what you
do against Ohio State you know I I know
that we're not quite sure how good
Clemson is but the are defending champs
great running back they got a great
quarterback defense isn't as good as
last year but Clemson against Ohio State
what do you make of that well first of
all I don't know how good comes in is
because I've seen this time and time
again and we've seen this time and time
again they have the easiest pass every
year and I would argue this might give
you a fascinating history of college
football with what they had to go to get
to the playoff but you look at the dudes
they have they got dudes Dan I mean they
got guys like Ross and Higgins out wide
that are six foot four six foot five
wide receivers that can make plays Kevin
Lawrence has been spin that thing and
finally you know got over a little bit
of a sophomore slump the way he started
his season my way it's hard when you
have humps like me talking about Trevor
Lawrence in the offseason saying hey if
he left right now if their freshman year
he's gonna be the number one thing he
heard that all offseason he heard how
great he was and I think once he started
clicking and taking what the defense
gives them and not turn the football
over now you know they can win they can
win it all out there Simmons is one of
the best defensive play makers in
college football I think it would be a
actually showdown you got two running
backs that are probably two of the more
underrated machines you know you're
going to talk about fields a lot and
you're going to talk about Lawrence a
lot etn you know he's only averaging
about 19 yards to carry his career
that's you know he's okay Dan he's going
to do the trick and then JK Dobbins
every big game for Ohio State
you know he's carried the ball 30-plus
times and it had over 150 yards and been
a key cog so man you got playmakers
falou they'd be interesting to watch
chase young you know the number one pick
maybe this year chasing around Trevor
Lawrence maybe the number one pick next
year and there will not be a shortage of
dude because you're gonna see on NFL
Sundays and Monday Night Football the
future give me the quarterback that you
would not want to face out of these
final four oh okay yo bro and it ain't
close bro I mean they just I tell you
what he just marvel at this kid and what
he's been able to accomplish and
I would I would if the bangles you know
I'm an old Cincinnati Bengals I had a
long illustrious career a season in
three games the bangles but if I'm the
bangles I'm taking him number one Dan
and I'm saying Joe Brady you're coming
with me as my offensive coordinator and
we're going to go wreck the NFL and I
tell you what the reason Jill borough
first of all he's you know he's an older
guy that's been through some stuff and
you could tell you know he goes to Ohio
State doesn't work out transfers to LSU
he's not in classes the dude is a
professional quarterback I mean studies
the game like crazy knows the game and
here's the thing he has the best
accuracy I've ever seen in college
football I mean the ball hit these guys
in stride in the numbers right here
right where they need it with couple
that with a system that's very new
school and they attack every part of the
field has weapons all over the field and
by the way so not only do they have
answers for every single coverage you
want to throw at them and athletes that
can win at every single level you got if
you're not watching him the dudes of
freaky athlete too I mean he is he
completed a 20-yard pass to himself the
other day Dan who does that crap I mean
it was awesome wait wait let me go back
wait Boro doesn't go to clay so he's
he's a professional quarterback in LSU
he's not enrolled in classes hey take it
online classes he go to class he go to
school he literally a professional
quarterback he's doing a great job of it
so it's his ability to really justify
time break tackles he's he's got a sixth
sense a spider sense of when somebody if
one person is coming on and he's like a
I'm not worried about one person if two
people are coming out and like all right
now it might be a little bit worried but
there's been sick it's been one of
coolest stories in college football to
watch LSU stone-age offense come to the
new world and just destroy people yeah
this might be I'm trying to think the
largest margin for a Heisman Trophy
winner who finishes runner-up here I
have no clue
I mean oh you have a certain amount of
votes remember to be at the Sarah's
gonna be there
you know just might be there vibes
because even I feels and Dobyns and
chase young are all gonna you know split
boats
you know just Trevor Lawrence climbed
back in this thing it's not meant to of
obviously out it's it's kind of you know
hey Joe just just come by yourself Joe
and we'll announce you to winter we're
talking to David Pollock College GameDay
concludes its regular season this
Saturday live from army-navy that'll
start at 9:00 a.m. Eastern on the
mothership do we all win that Lane
Kiffin is now back in the SEC yes
nothing the media type of course I think
you know Lane is not going to be afraid
to take shots and you know it's he's
first of all he's been offensive on time
he's definitely you know a genius and a
great play caller I'm just I'm very
curious to see if if that guy does
continue to be inside of him because I
hope he matured and I hope he learned
from his you know his mess-ups and I
hope he hope he got a little bit more
structured listen this guy's always been
a great play caller but building a team
and being the mature adult in the room
and making sure he's leading the guys
and demanding of them I think he's
lacked some of that in the past and he
talked about on our show yesterday I was
in fracture he's like let something
happen without Nick Saban and so he was
very thankful for Nick saving his time
he got to go spend with Nick and now
when he comes in to Ole Miss how soon
before he takes a shot at Nick or Texas
filling it Nick I don't think it'll be
long but just don't miss it this is an
interesting spot for Ole Miss because
you know that's a hire that I'm not sure
everybody's always on board with and I
know everybody on board with but maybe
not be on board with there but they're
going to give him a try and continuing
that offensive footprint of when they
were really good with few fries a couple
years ago it was having a great
offensive coach and I think that's what
they're looking for one more item I saw
this as a possibility for the head
coaching position with the Washington
Redskins David Shaw with Stanford I
don't know if there's any validity to it
but his name has been mentioned before
they had a down year at Stanford
could you see David Shaw maybe this year
jumping to the NFL he's got a couple of
down years and and I tell you what I
think that I don't know what you want
all it but I think the run and remember
remember the intellectual brutality and
the Stanford facade is definitely gone I
you know I think he would be a
phenomenal coach at the next level he
relates the kids really really well I
don't know if he would leave but he
would be a great coach he would be a
great guy at this level I mean if you're
gonna start mentioning guys David Shaw
Lincoln Reilly Matt rule you know those
are three that come to mind right away
transferring from from college that you
know would do really really well the
next level and David Shaw he hello it's
in the NFL changing and you've seen you
know golly I'm watching the NFL and I'm
watching the 49ers yesterday and
watching Rick plays to Luther and
watching the Patriots and it's trick
plays and watching Lamar Jackson and
Josh Allen and you're seeing way more
you know Andy Reid and Patrick mahomes
you're seeing way more elements of
college football but David Shaw is a
welcome and respect of everybody he I
think he'd be very successful NFL coach
but Washington isn't the best
destination I don't think me successful
it's been a hot minute David thanks for
joining us as always we'll be watching
this weekend army navy starts at 9:00
a.m. Eastern on ESPN thank you David
David Pauley for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]